[Musica]
buonasera a tutti durante la seconda
guerra mondiale un ammiraglio francese
durante una riunione con i suoi
ufficiali poiché c'era il problema molto
serio dei famigerati sommergibili
tedeschi u boat che produssero delle
devastazioni al naviglio diciamo degli
avversari
disse in una riunione ai suoi ufficiali
voi dovete fare bollire l'acqua del mare
in maniera tale che gli u boat saranno
costretti ad emergere e noi li potremmo
catturare perché gli ufficiali fecero
presente non senza qualche timore
reverenziale all'ammiraglio sì ma
esattamente noi come possiamo fare a far
bollire l'acqua del mare e l'ammiraglio
rispose io mi occupo di strategie e non
di tattiche allora questa questo è il
preludio è l'antefatto
poi magari spero che sarà come dire più
intelligibile sulla finale del mio
speech ma in caso qualcuno se vuole
chiamare uno psichiatra diciamo cioè se
anche la possibilità tra le perversioni
che io mi riconosco perché ho un
discreto livello di autocoscienza c'è
anche quella di avere una profonda
ammirazione per la confederazione
svizzera e per le prassi democratiche
della confederazione svizzera nello
specifico per la loro forma di
democrazia diretta per la possibilità
quindi che i cittadini possano lanciare
dei referendum non solo abrogativi ma
anche propositivi addirittura con una
valenza costituzionale cioè si va alle
urne
e se vince il si ad un quesito si scrive
un articolo della costituzione che è una
cosa molto affascinante l'apoteosi della
democrazia diretta
tre anni fa esattamente tre anni fa nel
febbraio del 2014
i cittadini svizzeri andarono alle urne
per decidere un quesito di rango
costituzionale che prevedeva
l'imposizione di contingenti
all'immigrazione inclusa
l'immigrazione dall'unione europea
il referendum
con una vittoria di misura circa 20 mila
voti di scarto a favore del sì pertanto
venne scritto un articolo 121 a della
costituzione svizzera e stabilire questo
principio ora diciamo in condizioni
normali quello che è scritto su una
costituzione dovrebbe avere un seguito
operativo a livello di leggi quindi
venne dato al parlamento federale
svizzero un arco temporale di tre anni
per legiferare
subito dopo l'esito della consultazione
referendaria gli svizzeri scoprirono non
senza qualche perplessità che come dire
loro hanno firmato nel corso dei decenni
decine di accordi bilaterali con
l'unione europea rispetto ai quali la
svizzera può accedere al mercato unico
europeo
però come contropartita tra le altre
cose deve dare la libera circolazione
delle persone
quindi da una parte il nuovo articolo
della costituzione che parla di
contingenti all'immigrazione dall'altra
parte tutti gli accordi bilaterali che
sono parte se volete anche della
prosperità della confederazione
quindi la situazione sfuggire ap da
mente di mano cioè di fu un vero e
proprio psicodramma nazionale da una
parte quelli che dicevano la
costituzione è sacra non bisogna
toccarla l'esito il popolo è sovrano
eccetera e dall'altra parte quelli che
dicevano guardate che forse abbiamo un
problema
alla fine dopo tre anni di sofferenze
che cosa sia deciso che cosa ha
legiferato il parlamento che in caso di
disoccupazione più alta di una data
soglia critica che verrà stabilita in
alcune zone del paese e rispetto ad
alcuni profili professionali i datori di
lavoro svizzeri hanno l'obbligo di
convocare a colloquio segnalati dagli
uffici di collocamento cittadini
svizzeri cioè i cosiddetti indigeni
devono esaminarli e devono valutare se
questi cittadini fanno al caso loro
sulle richieste di assunzione questo non
è come avrete intuito l'esito di quella
consultazione referendaria perché
il datore di lavoro svizzero convoca
l'indigeno ser indigeno non gli sta bene
lo congeda lo ringrazia non deve
motivare perché gli sta bene e procede
ad assumere un cittadino non elvetico
questa è l'essenza di una violazione
della volontà popolare e di un articolo
della costituzione cioe ne racconto
un'altra che forse un po meno eclatante
però altrettanto curiosa interessante
sempre relativamente ad un referendum
voi saprete che europa è una delle
agenzie dell'unione europea e l'agenzia
dell'unione europea che si occupa del
coordinamento delle attività di polizia
che è una cosa estremamente importante
quindi lo scambio di informazioni per
prevenire la criminalità organizzata il
terrorismo eccetera si è deciso che
europa a partire dalla primavera
prossima dovrà diventare qualcosa di
molto più strutturato ma soprattutto
qualcosa dove i paesi decideranno a
maggioranza qualificata ma non più
all'unanimità questo è importante
siccome la danimarca ha la cosiddetta
clausola di opt out che è quella che dà
la facoltà al paese di chiamarsi fuori
da accordi dove non sia prevista all
unanimità il governo danese ha convocato
a dicembre del 2015 un referendum nel
quale si chiedeva di rinunciare a questa
clausola è di sostituirla con una
clausola di opt in
cioè il paese entrava in un accordo dove
si votava a maggioranza qualificata in
un più all'unanimità anche qui clamoroso
la popolazione con un margine un po più
ampio di quanto accaduto in svizzera ha
votato per respingere questa proposta è
questo che cosa ha determinato ha
determinato così ipso facto che la
danimarca è praticamente dal dicembre
2015 fuori da europol
ora siccome il coordinamento serve ecco
che anche qui è iniziato un processo
febbrile a mezzo dal quale si cerca di
salvare la forma del referendum e la
sostanza della cooperazione di polizia
perché semplicemente pensare di non
poter effettuare l'interscambio di
informazioni tra i paesi o farlo da
posizioni come dire di retrovia o
depotenziate è un rischio che nessun
governo e nessun paese può permettersi
quindi anche qui dopo circa un anno di
elaborazioni febbrili cosa sia deciso il
parlamento europeo proprio pochi giorni
fa ha raccomandato questa prassi si è
deciso che per il futuro dei funzionari
danesi siederanno nella struttura di
europol nell'agenzia fisica di europol
in una stanza diversa da quella dove
sono seduti tutti gli altri esponenti di
paesi che hanno aderito alla
cooperazione a maggioranza qualificata
se un agente di polizia danese o se una
autorità di polizia danese ha bisogno di
avere uno scambio di informazioni con
europol telefona o manda un flusso di
dati alla ai propri rappresentanti
danesi che sono seduti in questa stanza
il rappresentante danese si alza dalla
sua stanza va nella stanza a fianco e
sottopone la richiesta ai colleghi
europei che fanno parte a pieno titolo
di europol
anche in questo caso voi capite che la
situazione è abbastanza tragicomica nel
senso
noi abbiamo praticamente da un lato la
volontà popolare
dall'altro lato che cosa l'esigenza di
cooperazione
se volete anche il vincolo di realtà
allora come si legga questi quest
aneddotica che vi ho raccontato sin qui
con l'introduzione quella di degli u
boat come catturare gli u boat nel senso
che non ho scoperto nulla di clamoroso
per cui diciamo
non stiamo facendo la storia in questo
momento c'è una insopprimibile esigenza
nel nell'essere umano di ridurre l'ansia
e l'effetto ansiogeno della complessità
ambientale
la complessità ambientale che c'era
voglio dire ai tempi degli u boat quindi
durante la seconda guerra mondiale e che
nella nostra società attuale è
amplificata in maniera esponenziale
quindi noi siamo sottoposti ad un
continuo bombardamento informativo
sensoriale di una irruzione dell'alieno
se vogliamo dire nelle nostre vite e
tutto quello che magari delle vite ad
alta varianza ad alta variabilità e
quindi questo che cosa provoca provoca
in sicurezza e ansia
a volte provoca anche in sicurezza
economica che poi a sua volta genera un
ansia altrettanto potente quindi qual è
la domanda è l'esigenza che sorge in un
contesto del genere ma il fatto di
trovare quelli che io definisco i
proiettili d'argento cioè delle
soluzioni rapide semplici immediate a
problemi complessi
tuttavia questa è una fallacia perché
non esiste nessun proiettile d'argento
in una società complessa ma soprattutto
in una società che per sua natura sta
continuamente evolvendo verso una
esigenza di cooperazione e coordinamento
cioè noi siamo condannati che ci piaccia
o meno a interagire con chi ci sta
vicino su vari piani a vari livelli di
distanza ea creare un continuo negoziato
con questi soggetti
quando le cose vanno bene cioè quando il
contesto esterno ci è favorevole
questa cooperazione non ci costa molto
alla fine è una soluzione win win di cui
tutti siamo molto soddisfatti quando la
situazione peggiora quando ad esempio
c'è un
problema economico abbastanza
generalizzato quando ci sono delle
incertezze delle incoerenze eccetera e
quando le risorse a disposizione per
raggiungere l'obiettivo calano
ecco che in noi insorge e subentra
questa profonda insoddisfazione per gli
esiti del negoziato il negoziato viene
visto con un crescente fastidio il
negoziato come insostenibile vincolo
esterno sulla nostra libertà sulla
nostra autodeterminazione sulla capacità
di essere padroni del nostro destino e
di riprendere il controllo
purtroppo in questa fase quella della
grande insoddisfazione perché il minimo
comune denominatore non ci basta ci dà
degli esiti insoddisfacenti e frustranti
compare nella comunicazione politica ma
anche nel desiderio di sfidare
quest'ansia il proiettile d'argento cioè
la soluzione immediata tanto immediata
quanto fallace a problemi complessi
questo che cosa determina che chiunque
diciamo tenti di applicare una soluzione
di questo tipo va incontro a delle
delusioni e ha delle disillusioni che a
volte possono essere particolarmente
traumatiche e possono generare degli
effetti di stress di frustrazione che a
volte possono anche minacciare l'essenza
stessa della società lacerandone il
tessuto
quindi qual è il messaggio che io vorrei
dare sperando che riesca comunque ad
essere un messaggio ottimistico per me
la cooperazione è qualcosa di faticoso
qualcosa però che anche imprescindibile
perché non esistono soluzioni semplici a
problemi complessi
chiunque venga da voi a dirli ma guarda
che è facilissimo si può fare così
abbiamo risolto il problema dovrebbe
suscitare una sorta di dovrebbe far
suonare dovrebbe far accendere un
campanello d'allarme perché queste sono
le situazioni di reale pericolo perché
il vincolo di realtà e la complessità ci
condannano alla cooperazione ma possono
essere qualcosa che è tanto faticoso
quanto gratificante se si riesce a
portare fuori questo discorso
in conclusione
quello che io vorrei dire ispirandomi ad
una ad una quota ad una citazione di
groucho marx e che come vedete io non è
che mi faccia impazzire la realtà e il
suo vincolo di realtà ma tuttavia la
realtà è l'unico posto dove io posso
ottenere un pasto decente
questa frase me piace moltissimo perché
in un momento in cui la comunicazione
tende ad essere iper semplificata però
in funzione come dire ansiolitica ea
offrire pasti gratis che di fatto non
esistono
la metafora del pasto allora dovrebbe
aiutarci a pensare in maniera un po più
approfondita e strutturata per chetare
un pasto gratis che non esiste per
definizione non solo per gli economisti
con tutte le loro fissazioni e i loro
stati gli psicotici e un pasto decente
bisogna sempre e comunque puntare al
pasto decente
perché questo serve ad evitare dei
risvegli particolarmente traumatici
vi ringrazio per l'attenzione
[Applauso]
[Musica]